bonsoir avec ses poulains merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
emmanuel macron avait prévenu lors de la
dernière campagne présidentielle je cite
c'est moi ou le chaos
à un an de la fin de son mandat la
situation ressemble de plus en plus haut
au chaos du moins en matière de
communication gouvernementale oui alors
c'est vrai que cette promesse moi ou le
chaos n'est pas devenue une prophétie et
on a vraiment l'impression que c'est le
chaos
on compte en tout cas ce qui concerne la
communication du gouvernement
on a eu une annonce selon le jdd
dimanche les bleus les maquereaux allait
parler cette semaine pour annoncer de
grandes choses et puis non démentie il
ne parlera pas cette semaine donc on est
suspendu aux lèvres du président que
va-t-il dire mes côtés de jean castex du
premier ministre c'est pas mieux
il annonce aux députés qu'il y aura un
conseil de défense de pain qu'il met la
santé avant toute chose qui le prend
aussi en compte les impacts qui existent
de ces stratégies erratique sur la santé
psychologique sur l'économie également
tout ça est dans le tuyau on a
l'impression que finalement les 66
millions de procureur commence à peser
sur les décisions de l'exécutif qui
redescend de l'olympe
mais aussi le choix des personnels
scientifiques puisque côté conseil
scientifique c'est aussi un pédalage un
rétropédalage du professeur delfraissy
comme vous venez de le dire
dimanche il se veut extrêmement
alarmiste parlant de ce virus diabolique
et puis finalement il se dit qu'on peut
attendre trois jours une semaine
il n'y a pas d'urgence donc tout ça est
vraiment dans un degré d'impréparation
et de chaos communicationnel assez
terrible et puis rappelons les chiffres
on en est à 26000 contamination hier
plus de 3000 hospitalisation le curseur
qui avait été mis par le président la
république en décembre c'était 5000 cas
par jour pour des cons fine et donc on
en est vraiment loin aujourd'hui
alors on parle de la communication
gouvernementale mais est ce qu'on peut
parler aussi de chaos en matière de
stratégie sanitaire
alors oui là aussi on ne comprend plus
rien le ministre de la santé qui est un
des trois rares ministres autorisé à
prendre la parole en public annonçait
olivier ferrand le matin devant le
cénacle objectif était de vacciner 15
millions de personnes avant l'été
personnes avec des faiblesses des
comorbidités et d'aidés publiques à
risque et puis le soir sur le plateau
d'invités il annonçait 70 millions de
français vaccinés après l'été très
rapidement sachant qu'on est que 67
millions de français donc tout le monde
se pose la question mais d'où il sort
ses trois millions de français
supplémentaires
il n'a jamais répondu et puis côté
vaccins alors là c'est quand même
incroyable
aujourd'hui on a décidé que non on
allongerait pas la durée d'injection
entre la première piqûre et la deuxième
piqûre et qu'on s'en tiendraient aux
recommandations des labos tant mieux
mais la question se pose parce qu'on est
toujours dense et ce risque de ne pas
avoir suffisamment de doses
puisque les vaccins qui est les
candidats vaccins qui avait été commandé
notamment sanofi vaccin français ou
pasteur pasteur a jeté l'épongé sur le
vaccin il va se concentrer sur d'autres
solutions et c'est un peu partout pareil
on apprend que sanofi lui produira des
doses plus tard pour pouvoir produire du
vaccin
kaiser mais on reste toujours là on
encore dans le
l'impréparation et le sis à savoir
est-ce qu'on va recevoir suffisamment de
doses est-ce que les vaccins vont
fonctionner avec tous ces variants là
encore on navigue à vue et ce n'est pas
très rassurant
alors bruno le maire lui dit eh bien il
faut faire confiance au génie français à
la start up nation et il appelle les
entreprises françaises des
biotechnologies à être audacieuse à
prendre des risques et à créer de
nouveaux protocoles aussi pourquoi pas
trouver des nouveaux médicaments
c'est quand même assez spécial sachant
qu'il existe déjà des médicaments
l'alcool ce qui nous parle de cole
corona il y avait la chloroquine on
essaye des choses des deux protocoles il
ya autre chose que les vaccins il va
falloir peut-être se résoudre à trouver
autrement
alex et poulard venez de parler alain
stands
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
justement matière économique
à quoi faut-il s'attendre est ce qu'il
faut craindre des choses alors oui
beaucoup à craindre parce que je le
crois qu'il en coûte devient ça va
coûter vraiment trop cher il ya des
notes qui commencent à fuiter de bercy
disant que trois mois de plus et on ne
pourra pas tenir le soutien qu'on fait
aux entreprises qu'on demande à auxquels
on demande de fermer il faut se rappeler
les déclarations de bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui sur l'antenne
d'une radio nationale parlait de 6% de
croissance en disant vous inquiétez pas
y aura un rebond en 2021 ça c'était à la
fin de la dernière puis en début d'année
il revient à la radio pour dire écoutez
on garde les 6% mais ce sera un défi
et puis la plus récemment il dit bon 6%
alors là ça va être très difficile
surtout si on recompte fine le medef qui
dit car confinement sera intenable
les entreprises aussi qu'ils commencent
à témoigner de leur difficulté à la fois
d'avoir des aides et de tenir on pas
d'une pme sur deux qui pourraient mettre
la clé sous la porte si on continue ses
stratégies sanitaires qui demande à tous
de fermer le fmi le fonds monétaire
international qui par son bureau
parisien est en train d'avancer des
pions pour dire qu'il va peut-être
falloir que la france fasse des réformes
commencent à s'intéresser à sa tête
corona parce qu'elle va être intenable
et que on se retrouverait sans doute en
france avec un scénario à la grecque
vous avez vu ce qui est arrivé en grèce
lors de la crise de 2008 eh bien
peut-être qu'avec cette crise sanitaire
du corona la france deviendrait la
nouvelle grèce en 2021 2022
donc ça devient intenable cette phrase
de moi ou le chaos elle est totalement
anachronique maintenant on voit que
quatre ans dans le mandat des modèles
macron c'est le chaos total
et je ne vois pas quel bilan il va
pouvoir défendre en 2022
s'il souhaite se représenter s'amène
extrêmement difficile et il faudra
changer de ritournelles entre moi et le
chaos parce que lors des derniers
sondages on a vu que pour un premier
tour potentiellement marine le pen
serait devant emmanuel macron lors de
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
merci alexis poulain
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes